haley over making his 18th start
those who aren't familiar he's a guy who
in the minor league's had great command
and he's added some velocity
had a lot of time to work on it last
year added some velocity to that
fastball he'll throw his fastball up
swit merrifield who's hitting 275.
lifts it to left center field and deep
and
will be bouncing off the chain-link
fence that way
tries to come in there that fastball but
get him out of there beautiful stroke
nikki lopez he has an eight-game hitting
streak he has a five-game hitting streak
with two or more hits
that'll get wit over to third
and simmons throws late he wasn't able
to get much on the throw
and the royals have runners at first and
third with nobody out oh
that's
a beauty he gets an infield knock gets
the runner over and an opportunity to
steal a base
look at he jam shot and simmons he knows
he can run
salvi hits a fastball to right field
and ref snyder is at the
[Applause]
kind of an afterthought after all those
breaking balls both royals will move up
wit scores on salvi's 105th rbi and
nikki lopez moves up to second base and
they'll be going up against chris bubich
for the fourth time this year
yeah you know what they're familiar with
[ __ ] huxton in his first at-bat so the
last two ball games has hit a couple of
tape measure home runs
driven to the corner
fair
off the limestone into the seats it'll
be a double
so bovich kept him in the ballpark but
barely
i guess technically he didn't it just
went out on one hop instead of on the
fly
that gets away
rivero
unable to control the pitch and buxton
moves up to third
that'll get the run in and a long run
for ben and tendy and he'll get there on
the edge of the track a rise with a
sacrifice fly and the twins even enough
at one alberto mondissie will lead off
the second inning he is hitless on the
trip
and monday pounds one to deep right
field and gone and bouncing out towards
the street here at target field a home
run by monday and the royals take the
two to one lead so now you've got two
quick guys on
with only one out
that's into short center
and now
they'll get the force play at third and
the double play
what an intelligent play
well whit merrifield let the ball land
and he got the force play at third in
the fourth play at second
here comes rocco baldelli to come out
and talk with rob drake about the play
but not high enough to be an infield fly
even though it looked like maybe he had
some intent but
backed up played it on the off and then
recognized where the runners were
incredible that's going to be the appeal
here for rocco baldelli as he talks to
the umpires
after the fact the infield fly rule has
been called i'll be shocked if matheny
stays in this game right here and i
think both rocco baldelli and mike
matheny have good cases to argue at its
apex how high was that ball and
is it an infield fly if the umpires
don't call it it was more of a little
soft liner and maryfield
did a nice job of retreating and they
discussed after rocco baldelli asked
home plate umpire rob drake for the
consultation
they are leaving the runners
at second and first
so we are still in
the
bottom of the third inning ref
schneider's out
they'll go as a f4 or pop four you know
the second baseman it'll count as a
fly ball out
to maryfield
short center long run for isbell and it
is merefield who makes the catch to end
the inning two left aboard the royals
still lean by
pulls it through the shift all right
and it's the right fielder ref snyder
coming over to get it
so good at bat for
ryan o'hearn and he's on
rivero pulls it to the left side and
that's through on an 02 pitch
and that'll put two on with one out
and the top of the order coming up face
wood field who comes up
with two on only one out
and his first big league pitch jams wit
but he gets it right on the line
[Applause]
o'hearn scores rivero goes to third whit
has his second double of the game and
the royals take a 3-1 lead oh yeah
wit going good today
line to left field and down for a base
hit
[Applause]
and the royals have their lead off man
on again
and ryan o'hearn takes a walk
and a four pitch walk
so a single
then two outs then two walks sebastian
rivero is coming up with the bases
loaded
and that is chopped out toward third
donaldson throws on the run and that's
all garza needs to get the twins out of
the sixth the royals leave the bases
loaded and tapia will come on with the
bases loaded and one out and the royals
leading by two
rooker o for two for his last nine and
the pitch line down the left field line
there's a base hit buxton scores ref
snyder being waved in throwing to third
base donaldson's safe
and rooker in the second base and twins
have tied it up
3-3 runners at the corners two outs and
isbell the battery be a difference maker
in this game first game back since april
isbell grounds it through the right side
so he is a difference maker
dozier comes around to score olivarez
stops at second
and kyle isbell in his first game back
from aaa puts the royals in front in the
eighth inning and now the twins with two
gift base runners have cenote to play
with one out
on the ground right to nikki lopez out
at second and a double play and stomach
pitches a scoreless eight
merifill down the line at third here's
the pitch there's a swing and this is
going to be deep enough carrying to the
outfield rooker with the catch
merrifield tags at third he comes home
and the royals go in front five to three
and he got him so scott barlow slams the
door on the twins
the royals take the series two games to
one and they finished the road trip four
and three that away scotty boy